was like a firework and that it was truly thrilling because it went off at the wrong time with a total disregard for bystanders and if they heard this i don't know what they'd do i didn't make this for them i made this for you in 2009 the dream was alive, and you were mine. Hi, this is Joel, and you're listening to the Taproot Therapy Collective podcast. Today I'm reading an article from our blog called The Anima of the Great Gatsby and the Animus of History. Cultures wax and wane. Empires that seem like part of the cosmos themselves
就像一场烟花，它确实令人激动，因为它在错误的时间燃放，完全不顾及旁观者。如果他们听到了这些，我不知道他们会怎么做。我写这些不是为了他们，而是为了你。2009年，梦想依然鲜活，而你曾属于我。你好，我是乔尔，你正在收听的是“主根疗法集体”（Taproot Therapy Collective）播客。今天，我将朗读我们博客上的一篇文章，题为《〈了不起的盖茨比〉中的阿尼玛与历史的阿尼姆斯》。文化有兴衰，那些看似宇宙一部分的帝国，
fall like a gunshot victim into a pool or lines on a bar chart. It is the rare work that can speak to both the sparkle of the spectacle and the timeless inevitable real that it distracts us from. The Great Gatsby was an immediate success and then forgotten and then rediscovered. It was forgotten because the Jazz Age was a beautiful, maybe, but still nearsighted, dalliance. Fitzgerald was lumped in with all of the other out-of-date, out-of-style gauche-ness
像枪击受害者一样倒在水池里，或者像条形图上的线条一样坠落。很少有作品能同时触及奇观的闪耀，以及它让我们分心的那个永恒且不可避免的现实。《了不起的盖茨比》曾获得即时成功，随后被遗忘，又被重新发现。它之所以被遗忘，是因为爵士时代是一场美丽但目光短浅的恋情。菲茨杰拉德被归入所有那些过时、老派、笨拙的行列中，
that the book was mistaken as a celebration of. It was rediscovered because critics realized that the book was like one of those sweet scented breakup notes that is written so beautifully that the dumped sod misreads it as a love letter and puts it with the other love notes unawares. The Great Gatsby was a warning and you can only hear the warning after the fall. Perhaps half love letter and half kiss off, some part of Fitzgerald knew that his world was ending. The Jazz Age was the parados, or the fun act of the ancient Greek tragedy where characters expound humorously against the chorus on the character faults that will
而这本书却被误认为是对此的赞美。它之所以被重新发现，是因为评论家们意识到，这本书就像那些写得极其优美的分手信，被甩的人误以为是情书，便不知不觉地把它和其他情书放在了一起。《了不起的盖茨比》是一个警示，而你只有在坠落之后才能听见这个警示。或许它一半是情书，一半是绝交信，菲茨杰拉德内心深处知道他的世界正在终结。爵士时代是古希腊悲剧中的“进场歌”（parados），即滑稽的表演部分，角色们在歌队面前幽默地阐述那些最终将
later undo them against the grinding unwinding of time. Ancient Greece and Rome looked the same in the periphery and quite different in focus. Greeks sought to be ideal through archetype, where Romans sought reality through realism. Greece, like F. Scott Fitzgerald, dealt in the realm of the anima, the passive, intuitive, and emotional aspect of the psyche. They were comfortable with beauty through vulnerability and had a poetic culture that celebrated poetic introspection. The Greeks were fascinated with the introspective world of the psyche and their ability to express complex emotions and ideas through symbolic and mythological language. To them, archetypes were like platonic forms or perfect ideals removed
导致他们毁灭的性格缺陷，对抗着时间的磨损与消解。古希腊和古罗马在边缘处看起来相似，但在焦点上却截然不同。希腊人通过原型追求理想，而罗马人通过现实主义追求现实。希腊，就像F·斯科特·菲茨杰拉德一样，处理的是阿尼玛（anima）领域，即心灵中被动、直觉和感性的一面。他们乐于通过脆弱来展现美，并拥有赞美诗意内省的诗性文化。希腊人痴迷于内省的心灵世界，以及他们通过象征和神话语言表达复杂情感和思想的能力。对他们来说，原型就像柏拉图式的形式或完美的理想，脱离了
from time a common bit of conventional wisdom is that Greek made their gods into men and Romans made their men into gods when you look at Greek sculpture there is this perfect quality where all blemishes are stripped away. It is the perfect ideal or archetype of the man. Roman masculinity, Roman beauty celebrated the ugliness, the realistic, the more masculine part of self, you know, the animus. You know. Rome, like Fitzgerald's contemporary Ernest Hemingway, was more closely associated with the qualities of the animus, the masculine, assertive, and imperialistic aspect of the psyche, the ego-expanding quality, not ego-dissolving, introspecting quality like the anima. Roman culture was characterized by its emphasis on law,
时间。一个常见的传统智慧是：希腊人把神变成了人，而罗马人把人变成了神。当你观察希腊雕塑时，有一种完美的特质，所有的瑕疵都被剥离了。那是人的完美理想或原型。罗马的阳刚之气、罗马的美，赞美的是丑陋、现实、自我中更具男性化的一部分，也就是阿尼姆斯（animus）。你知道的。罗马，就像菲茨杰拉德的同时代人欧内斯特·海明威一样，与阿尼姆斯的特质联系得更紧密——即心灵中男性化、果断和帝国主义的一面，那种扩张自我的特质，而不是像阿尼玛那样消解自我、内省的特质。罗马文化以其对法律、
order, and external appearances of military might. It gave rise to some of the most impressive feats of engineering, architecture, and political organization in the ancient world. The Romans were known for their practicality, their discipline, and their ability to translate ideas into concrete realities. To Rome, the aspirational and ideological only mattered in hindsight. To a Greek, one noticed the archetype or one failed to. To a Roman, one created the archetype. Humans made things real or we didn't. Romans got credit for ideas in a way that Greeks didn't. To a Greek, we were glimpsing the inevitable realm of the possible through cognition. Time was cyclical.
秩序和军事力量的外在表现为特征。它在古代世界创造了一些最令人印象深刻的工程、建筑和政治组织成就。罗马人以其实用性、纪律性以及将思想转化为具体现实的能力而闻名。对罗马人来说，抱负和意识形态只有在事后才重要。对希腊人来说，要么注意到原型，要么就失败了。对罗马人来说，人创造了原型。人类让事物变得真实，否则我们就没做到。罗马人因思想而获得赞誉，而希腊人则不然。对希腊人来说，我们是通过认知瞥见了必然的可能领域。时间是循环的。
Ideas were external. You didn't have ideas. They just had you for a minute. For Romans, a man came up with the idea and deserved credit. This is an interesting dichotomy because both ideas are true, but paradoxical ways of studying the way that we think. Something like object relations. There are different sides of that argument, or different sides of that dichotomy. All of the early modernist writers, Fitzgerald's time, they engaged with this dialect differently. Fitzgerald leaned Greek animistic, Hemingway leaned into the Roman animus, and other contemporaries like Gertrude Stein tried to bridge the divide and integrate both
思想是外在的。你并没有拥有思想，它们只是暂时占据了你。对于罗马人来说，一个人提出了想法，就理应获得赞誉。这是一个有趣的二分法，因为这两个观点都是正确的，但却是研究我们思维方式的矛盾方法。就像客体关系理论。那个论点有不同的侧面，或者说那个二分法有不同的侧面。所有早期的现代主义作家，即菲茨杰拉德那个时代的人，都以不同的方式处理这种辩证法。菲茨杰拉德倾向于希腊式的阿尼玛，海明威倾向于罗马式的阿尼姆斯，而其他同时代人如格特鲁德·斯泰因则试图弥合这种分歧，并整合这两种
of these kind of psychic forces. There was no way around, as literature progressed, confronting that expression of what the self was. Greece and Rome were also deeply interconnected and mutually influential. Greek art, literature, and philosophy had a profound impact on Roman culture, and many Romans saw themselves as the heirs and stewards of the Greek intellectual tradition. At the same time, Roman law, government, and military power provided a framework for the spread and preservation of Greek ideas through the Mediterranean world. We need both the anima and the animus to be the whole self, effective at wrestling the present and possible together
心理力量。随着文学的发展，无法回避的是要面对那种关于自我本质的表达。希腊和罗马也深度互联并相互影响。希腊的艺术、文学和哲学对罗马文化产生了深远影响，许多罗马人视自己为希腊知识传统的继承者和守护者。与此同时，罗马的法律、政府和军事力量为希腊思想在地中海世界的传播和保存提供了框架。我们需要阿尼玛和阿尼姆斯来成为完整的自我，有效地将当下与可能结合起来，
if we are to be effective at acting on the impending real. The intuition of the anima can let us see the future through dreams of creativity and visions for the possible, but the animus is what lets us bring our agency to bear on the present moment. It is easy to hide in either one, but when you do, you miss the both. I read The Great Gatsby in high school, and it was one of the few assigned readings that I didn't hate. I wanted to read Michael Crichton and classical mythology primary sources, but the curriculum wanted me to slog through things like Nathaniel Hawthorne and Zora Neale Hurston. I enjoyed the points that those authors made, criticizing Puritanism and celebrating African American folk culture respectively, but I thought that the stylism made reading them a slog. The Great Gatsby was simple, and I have reflected on it over the course of my life. Luckily, if you're trying to read a book in the early 2000s that they don't want you to have in
如果我们想要有效地作用于即将到来的现实。阿尼玛的直觉能让我们通过创造性的梦想和对可能的愿景看到未来，但阿尼姆斯是让我们将行动力施加于当下的力量。躲在其中任何一个里面都很容易，但当你这样做时，你就错过了两者。我在高中读了《了不起的盖茨比》，它是少数几本我不讨厌的指定读物之一。我想读迈克尔·克莱顿和古典神话的原始资料，但课程要求我费力地阅读纳撒尼尔·霍桑和佐拉·尼尔·赫斯顿的作品。我欣赏那些作者提出的观点，分别批评清教主义和赞美非裔美国人民间文化，但我认为那种文风让阅读变得枯燥乏味。《了不起的盖茨比》很简单，我一生中多次反思过它。幸运的是，如果你在21世纪初试图读一本学校不希望你读的书，
school, they made these things called cargo pants that fit a 500-page Wheel of Time novel perfectly. In high school, I saw Hemingway and Fitzgerald as two halves of the same coin. Fitzgerald was the nostalgic reflective anima to Hemingway's masculine animus. Hemingway jumped headlong into the morphine promises of modernism, and Fitzgerald seemed to reflect on modernity a little bit more honestly to me because he was pulled begrudgingly into it while trying to look further and further back into the past and its inevitabilities of illusions of progress. Most of my friends were manly Hemingways who were comfortable in the logos of the accessible real, and I was a navel-gazing Fitzgerald who only felt comfortable cloaked in the mythos of
他们发明了一种叫工装裤的东西，正好能装下一本500页的《时光之轮》小说。在高中时，我把海明威和菲茨杰拉德看作同一枚硬币的两面。菲茨杰拉德是怀旧、反思的阿尼玛，而海明威则是阳刚的阿尼姆斯。海明威一头扎进了现代主义的吗啡承诺中，而菲茨杰拉德对我来说似乎更诚实地反思了现代性，因为他是在试图回望过去及其进步幻觉的必然性时，不情愿地被卷入其中的。我的大多数朋友都是充满男子气概的海明威式人物，他们对可触及现实的逻辑感到舒适，而我是一个沉溺于自我反思的菲茨杰拉德，只有披上神话的外衣才感到自在，
intuitive space. In Jungian psychology, invented by Jungian psychologist Carl Jung, the concepts of anima and animus are crucial for understanding the inner world of the creative. The anima represents the feminine aspects within the male psyche, while the animus represents the masculine aspects within the female psyche. A healthy integration of these archetypes is essential for wholeness in the person's personal life, you know, behind the creative works. As a therapist, I find that those and other Jungian concepts usefully help me understand why certain people gravitate naturally to different things over the course of their life. Fitzgerald's life and work were dominated by his anima, which manifested in his nostalgic yearning for the past, his romantic idealization of many, many women, and his sensitivity to the nuances of emotion and beauty. While these qualities fueled his artistic genius, they also left him vulnerable to depression, addiction, and a sense of alienation from the modern world. It was this alienation from modernism while writing
在荣格心理学中（由荣格心理学家卡尔·荣格创立），阿尼玛和阿尼姆斯的概念对于理解创作者的内心世界至关重要。阿尼玛代表男性心灵中的女性特质，而阿尼姆斯代表女性心灵中的男性特质。这些原型的健康整合对于个人生活的完整性至关重要，你知道，在创作作品的背后。作为一名治疗师，我发现这些以及其他荣格概念能有效地帮助我理解为什么某些人在一生中会自然地倾向于不同的事物。菲茨杰拉德的生活和作品被他的阿尼玛所主导，这体现在他对过去的怀旧渴望、他对许多女性的浪漫理想化，以及他对情感和美感的细微差别的敏感。虽然这些特质激发了他的艺术天赋，但也使他容易受到抑郁、成瘾和与现代世界疏离感的影响。正是这种在写作时与现代主义的疏离，
as a modernist that gave Gatsby a timeless predictive quality that Hemingway lacks. Ultimately, he was able to predict the future as a creative, but unable to adapt to it as a man. Hemingway, on the other hand, embodied the over-identified animus, the archetypal masculine energy that values strength, independence, and action. Above all else, it is the ego-expanding element of a person that would lead them to do something like create an empire. instead of dissolve themselves into the creative flow or fall in love. His writing, or to contact the intuition that might let one predict the future in the way that I would argue Fitzgerald did, whether or not he knew it.
作为一名现代主义者，这赋予了《盖茨比》一种海明威所缺乏的永恒的预见性。最终，他作为一名创作者能够预见未来，却无法作为一个人去适应它。另一方面，海明威体现了过度认同的阿尼姆斯，即那种重视力量、独立和行动的原型男性能量。最重要的是，它是一个人扩张自我的要素，这会引导他们去做创造帝国之类的事情，而不是将自己溶解在创造性的流动中或坠入爱河。他的写作，或者说去接触那种可能让人以我所认为的菲茨杰拉德的方式预见未来的直觉，无论他是否意识到。
His writing, Hemingway's, celebrated the virtues of courage, stoicism, and physical prowess, and he cultivated a public image as a rugged adventurer of a man of action. However, this one-sided embrace of the animus left Hemingway emotionally stunted and unable to deeply connect with others or to find peace within himself. Hemingway is all bombastic adventure, and when the adventure is over, there was little left. One of their other contemporaries, Hemingway and Fitzgerald's contemporary, Gertrude Stein, seems to have been able to achieve a kind of dynamic balance between her masculine and feminine quality. This is not to say that she was free from all psychological
他的写作，即海明威的写作，赞美了勇气、坚忍和身体素质的优点，他塑造了一个粗犷的冒险家、行动派男人的公众形象。然而，这种对阿尼姆斯的片面拥抱使海明威在情感上发育迟缓，无法与他人建立深层联系，也无法在内心找到平静。海明威的一切都是夸张的冒险，当冒险结束时，所剩无几。他们的另一位同时代人，格特鲁德·斯泰因，似乎能够在她的男性和女性特质之间实现一种动态平衡。这并不是说她没有心理上的
conflicts or blind spots, but rather she was able to channel her energies into her work and her relationships in a way that was largely generative, sustainable, and life-affirming. Stein's work and life could be seen as an example of the transformative power of the anima and the animus within the psyche. Fitzgerald's own insecurities and traumas contributed significantly to his anima-dominated psyche and artistic worldview. Fitzgerald remained haunted throughout his life. Had he lived long enough to encounter Carl Jung's work, Fitzgerald would likely have been profoundly influenced by it. Jay Gatsby seems to be the Jungian archetype of the puer eternus, or eternal
冲突或盲点，而是她能够以一种在很大程度上具有生成性、可持续性和肯定生命的方式，将她的能量引导到她的工作和人际关系中。斯泰因的作品和生活可以被视为阿尼玛和阿尼姆斯在心灵中转化力量的一个例子。菲茨杰拉德自身的不安全感和创伤对他那阿尼玛主导的心灵和艺术世界观产生了重大影响。菲茨杰拉德一生都受到困扰。如果他活得足够长，能接触到卡尔·荣格的作品，他很可能会受到深刻的影响。杰伊·盖茨比似乎是“永恒少年”（puer eternus）的荣格原型，
boy, frozen by an impossible-to-attain object of desire and following a refusal to grow up. A charming, appealing, affecting, but ultimately failed visionary chasing red herrings or mirages. Fitzgerald himself seemed to go down the same path as other male Jungians, most notably James Hillman and Robert Moore, failing to fully ride the animus and integrate their assertive energies to manifest changes in their personal lives. All were beautiful artists, but not always beautiful men, especially in their end. There seems to be a common thread in these anima over-identified men, a childhood trauma that stifles self-expression, which paradoxically fosters a somewhat magical, intuitive, visionary ability to see the future, sometimes consciously, sometimes not.
被一个无法达到的欲望对象所冻结，并拒绝长大。一个迷人、吸引人、感人，但最终失败的梦想家，追逐着红鲱鱼或海市蜃楼。菲茨杰拉德本人似乎走上了与其他男性荣格学者（最著名的是詹姆斯·希尔曼和罗伯特·摩尔）相同的道路，未能完全驾驭阿尼姆斯并整合他们的果断能量来在个人生活中实现改变。他们都是美丽的艺术家，但并不总是美丽的男人，尤其是在他们生命的尽头。在这些过度认同阿尼玛的男性身上，似乎有一个共同点：童年创伤扼杀了自我表达，这反而培养了一种某种程度上神奇的、直觉的、有远见的能力来预见未来，有时是有意识的，有时则不是。
In adulthood, this ability makes one a profound artist, garnering success and a wide audience. However, the external validation and success do not heal the original still screaming wound. And this disconnect between outer success as from a failure to balm the inner pain, is something that many artists and depth psychologists of this personality type struggle to recover from. In high school, they told me The Great Gatsby was the greatest novel ever written and expected me to believe them. They also told me that getting straight A's meant that you were smart, that the hardest working got the highest paid, and that all they really wanted me to do was to think for myself. All were clearly lies that a sophistic system thought I was better off if I believed. Obviously, I had to find out later, pushing 40, that the book was onto something great.
在成年后，这种能力使人成为一位深刻的艺术家，获得成功和广泛的受众。然而，外部的认可和成功并不能治愈最初那道仍在尖叫的伤口。这种外部成功与未能抚平内心痛苦之间的脱节，是许多这种人格类型的艺术家和深度心理学家难以从中恢复的。在高中时，他们告诉我《了不起的盖茨比》是有史以来最伟大的小说，并期望我相信他们。他们还告诉我，拿全A意味着你很聪明，最努力工作的人拿最高的薪水，他们真正想让我做的只是独立思考。这些显然都是谎言，一个诡辩的系统认为如果我相信这些，我会过得更好。显然，我后来在快40岁时才发现，这本书确实触及了一些伟大的东西。
Or maybe you have to see the rise and fall of celebrity and missiles and trends and less obvious lies in your life before you start to get the book as its own second act. Saying that The Great Gatsby is a good book is like talking about how the Beatles were a great band or the Grand Canyon is big. It's kind of done to death and it's even silly to say out loud to someone. Everyone had to read it in high school. To say it is your favorite book instantly makes others wonder if you have ever read another book that you didn't have to read freshman year. Oh, Hamlet's your favorite other book? Thinks the person who knows that you have skimmed two books in your life and failed the test. How do you get the prescience of an extremely simple story at 16? How was anyone
或者也许你必须在生活中看到名流、导弹、趋势和不那么明显的谎言的兴衰，然后你才能开始把这本书当作它自己的第二幕。说《了不起的盖茨比》是一本好书，就像谈论披头士乐队是多么伟大的乐队，或者大峡谷有多大一样。这有点老生常谈，甚至大声对别人说出来都很傻。每个人在高中都必须读它。说它是你最喜欢的书，会立刻让别人怀疑你是否读过除了大一必须读的书之外的任何书。哦，《哈姆雷特》是你最喜欢的另一本书？那个知道你这辈子只粗略读过两本书且考试不及格的人会这样想。你如何在16岁时获得一个极其简单的故事的先见之明？谁又
supposed to get it in 1925? The Great Gatsby is, perhaps by accident, not really about what it is about. The Great Gatsby is a worm's eye view of the universe that reminds us that our humanity is itself a worm's eye view of the universe, and then our worm's eye view on it, and each other is what keeps us sane. Sane and the gears of the spectacle of culture grinding along out of psychic necessity. We are a myopic species stuck in our own stories and other stories, but not on our own terms. We are caught between improv and archetype, but never free of either, both subject to the human inevitable indelible programmed narrative and object of our own make-believe individual freedom from it. The Great Gatsby is
应该在1925年理解它呢？《了不起的盖茨比》或许是偶然的，它并不是真正关于它表面上所写的内容。《了不起的盖茨比》是一个“虫眼看宇宙”的视角，它提醒我们，我们的人性本身就是一种“虫眼看宇宙”的视角，而我们对它以及彼此的“虫眼视角”正是让我们保持理智的原因。理智，以及文化奇观的齿轮在心理需求下不断磨合。我们是一个短视的物种，困在自己的故事和其他人的故事中，但不是按我们自己的方式。我们被困在即兴创作和原型之间，但从未摆脱过任何一个，既受制于人类不可避免、不可磨灭的预设叙事，又是我们自己虚构的个人自由的客体。《了不起的盖茨比》是
a book that you read in high school because you could hand it to almost anyone. It has done numbers historically and currently as a work in translation. It holds up some kind of truth to students in places like Iran who have no experience with prohibition, with alcohol, or with American culture as insiders, yet they still feel something relevant connecting them to the real when they read the book, something human. It works because the characters are kind of stupid. It works because the moral of the story is on its face and, just like high school, kind of wrong. The Great Gatsby did see the future, it just didn't know what it saw. I write about intuition quite a bit on our blog, and the thing that I think makes art interesting is when the work of art sees past the knowledge of the artist making the work. The Great Gatsby
一本你在高中读的书，因为你可以把它递给几乎任何人。作为一部译作，它在历史上和目前都取得了巨大的成就。它向伊朗等地没有经历过禁酒令、没有接触过酒精、也没有作为内部人士接触过美国文化的学生们展示了某种真理，然而当他们读这本书时，他们仍然感受到某种相关的、连接他们与现实的东西，某种人性的东西。它之所以有效，是因为角色们有点愚蠢。它之所以有效，是因为故事的寓意就在表面上，而且就像高中一样，有点错误。《了不起的盖茨比》确实看到了未来，只是它不知道自己看到了什么。我在我们的博客上写了很多关于直觉的内容，我认为让艺术变得有趣的是，艺术作品看到了创造它的艺术家所不知道的东西。《了不起的盖茨比》
gets a lot of credit for being prophetic in that it saw the Great Depression as the end of the Jazz Age, but it did so because Fitzgerald was seeing his own end. Fitzgerald was severely alcoholic during Prohibition, delaying his own deadlines for the novel that almost didn't get there with excuses to his publishers. What would become of him after the Volstead Act was repealed? He was an alcoholic during prohibition. What would the country become after the economic bender that the upper class threw for itself in front of the masses that were starving? The power of the novel is when it knows that empires rise and fall. It's when it knows that the valley of ashes is watching your yellow car speed by with dull sad eyes. Its power is in knowing the feeling that when you get what you want, you don't really
因具有预言性而获得了很多赞誉，因为它看到了大萧条是爵士时代的终结，但它之所以这样做，是因为菲茨杰拉德看到了他自己的终结。菲茨杰拉德在禁酒令期间酗酒严重，推迟了小说的截止日期，几乎没能完成，并向出版商找借口。在《沃尔斯泰德法案》被废除后，他会变成什么样？他在禁酒令期间是个酒鬼。在富人阶层在饥饿的群众面前为自己举办经济狂欢之后，这个国家会变成什么样？小说的力量在于它知道帝国有兴衰。它在于它知道灰烬谷正用暗淡悲伤的眼睛看着你的黄色汽车疾驰而过。它的力量在于知道那种当你得到你想要的东西时，你并没有真正
deserve it, or maybe it doesn't deserve you. Maybe it implies that time is something that we use, take by talk, as a proxy for meaning because we fundamentally fumble with clocks, like Gatsby, and we can't understand time as humans. We need our history and our idolatry of the past to make meaning, but when the lens of our meaning-making remains fixed, the world becomes a pedestal to dark gods demanding the worship of the past at the expense of the future. As a man or as a nation, we are bound to hit someone if we look in the rearview mirror too
应得它，或者也许它不配拥有你的感觉。也许它暗示时间是我们用来作为意义代理的东西，因为我们像盖茨比一样，从根本上笨拙地摆弄时钟，我们无法像人类那样理解时间。我们需要历史和对过去的偶像崇拜来创造意义，但当我们赋予意义的镜头保持固定时，世界就变成了一个黑暗神的基座，要求以牺牲未来为代价来崇拜过去。作为一个男人或一个国家，如果我们盯着后视镜看太
long. The green light on the dock is a symbol that we mistake for the real thing, and we take the long walk off the short dock. With this dishonest relationship to time, we all become a Gatsby or a Tom. I'm not sure which is worse. We either lack all ambition and live to keep up appearances, or we have so much ambition that we become the lie. The beautiful shirts are just a glittering, stupid, trendy identity that we nationally put on every couple of years to forget that we're about to sink into another depression. Skinny ties are out, and now gunmetal is in.
久，我们注定会撞到某人。码头上的绿灯是一个我们误以为是真实事物的象征，我们从短码头上走远了。在这种与时间的不诚实关系中，我们都成了盖茨比或汤姆。我不确定哪个更糟。我们要么缺乏所有野心，活着只是为了维持表象；要么野心太大，以至于我们变成了谎言本身。那些漂亮的衬衫只是一个闪闪发光、愚蠢、时髦的身份，我们全国每隔几年就会穿上它，以忘记我们即将陷入另一次萧条。窄领带过时了，现在流行炮铜色。
Makes us never have to look at the other side of ourselves or our empire. The past gives us meaning and identity, even as it slowly destroys us and robs us of those things. We are forced to use it as a reference point, even though we know that this relationship between us and it is doomed, and we cannot stop the need for the next recession in this society any more than we can stop the need for the next recession in this society any more than we can stop the need for the next drawer of trendy clothes. The American dream is a kind of nightmare, but it is still a dream because it keeps us sleeping through the nightmare we are in. Realization of lost purpose, regret, nostalgia, superficiality, emotional turmoil, or tone-deaf foreshadowing are not
这让我们不必去审视我们自己或我们帝国的另一面。过去给了我们意义和身份，即使它正在慢慢摧毁我们并剥夺我们这些东西。我们被迫把它当作参考点，尽管我们知道我们与它之间的这种关系注定要失败，而且我们无法阻止这个社会对下一次衰退的需求，就像我们无法阻止对下一批时髦衣服的需求一样。美国梦是一种噩梦，但它仍然是一个梦，因为它让我们在身处的噩梦中继续沉睡。对失去目标的认识、遗憾、怀旧、肤浅、情感动荡或迟钝的预兆，都不是
things that you need to look at when movies and wars are inventing such beautiful coverings for our imperial core and rent-seeking economy. Why then do we cry? Wake up the organist. We are getting bored. In The Great Gatsby, like in a Dickens novel, the plot is the archetype, and that necessitates a lot of conveniences. That might seem like a point of criticism, but it is also very human. Perhaps these truths become tropes, are not faults of the plot or its contrivances, but reasons for our humanity, namely humans in America, to introspect. As individuals or as a society, we turn our insecurity into some amazing and impossible
当电影和战争正在为我们的帝国核心和寻租经济发明如此美丽的遮盖物时，你需要去审视的东西。那我们为什么要哭？叫醒管风琴手吧。我们感到无聊了。在《了不起的盖茨比》中，就像在狄更斯的小说中一样，情节就是原型，这需要很多便利。这看起来可能是一个批评点，但它也非常人性化。也许这些真理变成了陈词滥调，并不是情节或其安排的缺陷，而是我们人性（即在美国的人类）进行内省的原因。作为个人或社会，我们将不安全感转化为一些惊人且不可能的
outcomes, and then we, like Gatsby, do that to compensate for what we refuse to accept, what we refuse to change about who we are or where we come from. Jay Gatsby is myopic, but he is too naive to be a narcissist. He is just sort of a dream of himself that he forgot he was dreaming. Nothing in Fitzgerald's prose leans into The Great Gatsby being directly interpreted as a dream, but it is one possible interpretation that the novel is a sort of collective dream. There is a Tom Buchanan in all of us also, someone who would burn the world down just because we can't have the lie that we want
结果，然后我们像盖茨比一样，为了补偿我们拒绝接受的东西，为了补偿我们拒绝改变的关于我们是谁或我们来自哪里的东西，而这样做。杰伊·盖茨比是短视的，但他太天真了，不可能是自恋者。他只是一个他自己忘记了正在做梦的梦。菲茨杰拉德的散文中没有任何地方倾向于将《了不起的盖茨比》直接解释为一个梦，但一种可能的解释是，这部小说是一种集体梦。我们每个人心中也都有一个汤姆·布坎南，一个会烧毁世界的人，仅仅因为我们不能再拥有我们想要
others to believe about us anymore, or about our empire. He is a refusal to accept the reasonable limitations that might have prevented the Great Depression. If we can't have the whole world, then we'll blow the whole world up. That is another tension, still unresolved, that the Great Gatsby saw coming for humanity. The two forces of the lie and the dream are the things that make the boom and bust cycle of recession and surplus that have sustained America, sustained the lie and the dream are the things that make the boom and bust cycle of recession and surplus that have sustained America, sustained the lie, and the individual and the society. But shh, it's a dream, not a lie. Just like high school, the powers that be think that you are better off if you believe it.
别人相信关于我们的谎言，或者关于我们帝国的谎言。他拒绝接受那些本可以防止大萧条的合理限制。如果我们不能拥有整个世界，那我们就炸掉整个世界。这是另一个尚未解决的张力，《了不起的盖茨比》预见到了人类的这种张力。谎言和梦想这两种力量是造成支撑美国的衰退与盈余的繁荣与萧条周期的原因，支撑了谎言和梦想，是造成支撑美国的衰退与盈余的繁荣与萧条周期的原因，支撑了谎言，支撑了个人和社会。但嘘，这是一个梦，不是谎言。就像高中一样，当权者认为如果你相信它，你会过得更好。
Greece and Rome are relevant details to this reflection on a novel because neither one would have really mattered to history without the other half. Greece invented culture and religious structure, and Rome became the megaphone to amplify the expansion of that culture. We study them as high school students, but we don't want to see those distinctions even now. The predictive element in Fitzgerald made him live in a timeless present. His assumptions were, at worst, platonic archetypes, where all characters expressed endless inevitable cycles, and at worst, his characters were an Aristotelian ideal of knowledge, where his ideas had characters, so characters could not really
希腊和罗马是反思这部小说的相关细节，因为如果没有另一半，两者对历史都不会有真正的意义。希腊发明了文化和宗教结构，而罗马成为了放大这种文化扩张的扩音器。我们作为高中生学习它们，但即使现在我们也不想看到这些区别。菲茨杰拉德的预见性元素使他生活在一个永恒的当下。他的假设在最坏的情况下是柏拉图式的原型，所有角色都表达了无尽的必然循环；在最好的情况下，他的角色是亚里士多德式的知识理想，他的思想拥有角色，所以角色无法真正
have ideas. Hemingway lived in a Roman timeless present. Awareness of cycles of historical and social forces were not important. Maybe you identify with his archetype in his books, and maybe not. He could not see through them. America, when it needs to do advertising for a new product, movie, or war, will always side with Hemingway. I guess the old man in the sea feels important to the individual, but it lacks relevance to the pathos and the later demos that society needs to really introspect well. God is still a broken down billboard and the only, the stupid, or the insane in America can recognize God for what he is. If God is happy with what he
拥有思想。海明威生活在一个罗马式的永恒当下。对历史和社会力量循环的意识并不重要。也许你在他的书中认同他的原型，也许不。他无法看穿它们。美国在需要为新产品、电影或战争做广告时，总是会站在海明威一边。我想《老人与海》对个人来说感觉很重要，但它缺乏社会真正进行良好内省所需的悲剧色彩和后来的民众基础。上帝仍然是一个破旧的广告牌，只有美国的愚蠢者或疯子才能认出上帝的真面目。如果上帝对所见感到满意，
sees, then we clearly are too distracted to notice him. And if God is unhappy, then he does not approve of my America, so he must not really be my God. This is the double bind that the eyes of T.J. Echelbert, long out of business, put us in. Love me, and you must not be infallible. Dislike me, and you must be wrong. Fitzgerald ended his novel, but not his life, on the right note. Listen up, creatives. And so we beat on, boats against the current, ceaselessly borne back into the past. How do you end yours? How do you live it? You read it at 16, but how old are you now? The narrator, Nick Carraway, is a perfect observer because he is hopelessly naive, knowing nothing about human life or experience. He learns all of it in the course of a few days from the terrible follies of the gods
那么我们显然太分心而没有注意到他。如果上帝不高兴，那么他不赞同我的美国，所以他一定不是我真正的上帝。这就是早已倒闭的T·J·埃克尔伯格医生的眼睛让我们陷入的双重束缚。爱我，你就不能是无懈可击的；讨厌我，你就一定是错的。菲茨杰拉德以正确的音符结束了他的小说，但没有结束他的生活。听好了，创作者们。于是我们奋力向前，逆水行舟，不断地被推回到过去。你如何结束你的故事？你如何度过它？你在16岁时读了它，但你现在多大了？叙述者尼克·卡拉威是一个完美的观察者，因为他天真得无可救药，对人类生活或经验一无所知。他在几天内从他世界中诸神的恐怖愚行中学会了这一切，
of his world, the complete pantheon of all of the most powerful forces of the 20s, the real and the now. The traditional historic blue cover of The Great Gatsby juxtaposes the face of a 20s flapper with the skyline of a city lit for celebration. The flapper's face is studded with the traditional burlesque Cleopatra makeup that already juxtaposes a beauty mark with a teardrop in the cover. The rising celebration of a firework from the city skyline becomes a teardrop that is falling from the face at the same time is up and down forever. Really the same direction. The book asks you before you open it up. The Wall Street Journal tells you that the same thing is true today, but in more words. Fitzgerald never really found a way to see past himself.
那是20世纪20年代所有最强大力量的完整万神殿，即现实和当下。传统历史性的《了不起的盖茨比》蓝色封面将一位20年代摩登女郎的脸与一座为庆祝而灯火通明的城市天际线并置。摩登女郎的脸上画着传统的滑稽戏克利奥帕特拉妆容，封面中已经将一颗美人痣与一颗泪珠并置。从城市天际线升起的烟花庆祝活动变成了一颗从脸上落下的泪珠，同时向上和向下，永远如此。确实是同一个方向。在你打开书之前，它就问了你这个问题。《华尔街日报》告诉你今天同样的事情也是真的，只是用了更多的词。菲茨杰拉德从未真正找到一种看穿自己的方法。
Even when he wrote those truths in his fiction, he ended his career in Hollywood, helping better screenwriters by coasting on his reputation from the book that became a meteoric firework. In the end, he became a cautionary tale, a reminder that even the most gifted among us are not immune to the ravages of trauma and addiction masquerading as intuition and artistry, and the weight of unfulfilled dreams. What does Nick do with the lessons from the characters in this book when it ends in the autumn of 22? Did he make it out of the autumn-summer cycles of New York, of the booms and busts of the parties and the hangovers? Did he do anything with those lessons? Do any of us? Do we? Well, hello.
即使当他在小说中写下这些真理时，他也在好莱坞结束了他的职业生涯，靠着那本成为流星般烟花的小说所带来的声誉，帮助更好的编剧。最终，他成了一个警示故事，提醒人们即使是我们中最有天赋的人，也无法免疫创伤和成瘾伪装成直觉和艺术所带来的蹂躏，以及未竟梦想的重压。当这本书在22年秋天结束时，尼克如何处理从这些角色中学到的教训？他是否走出了纽约秋夏交替的循环，走出了派对和宿醉的繁荣与萧条？他是否利用这些教训做了什么？我们中有谁做到了吗？我们做到了吗？嗯，你好。
Oh, I get high. If you like this article, you can find it and many more on our blog at GetTherapyBirmingham.com. We also have a podcast that you can find at GetTherapyBirmingham.com that has a wide variety of content, essays like this, interviews with authors, creatives, Jungian analysts, and many more. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
哦，我兴奋了。如果你喜欢这篇文章，你可以在我们的博客 GetTherapyBirmingham.com 上找到它以及更多文章。我们还有一个播客，你可以在 GetTherapyBirmingham.com 上找到，里面有各种各样的内容，像这样的文章、对作者、创作者、荣格分析师的采访等等。这一集还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子即可发表评论。